* Dynamische Musik *
* Dynamische Schlagzeugmusik *
Hemden sind mein Beruf,
mein Leben, mein Hobby.
Sie sind das,
was ich immer machen wollte.
Die Musiker von früher
haben mich auf die Idee gebracht.
Die Beatles und Rolling Stones
trugen coole Hemden.
Später konnte ich mir das erfüllen.
* Dynamische Musik *
Ich suche allmählich
einen Nachfolger.
Ich möchte jemanden finden,
der das weiterführt
und Freude hat an dieser Marktlücke,
an diesen speziellen Hemden.
Irgendwann geht alles zu Ende
und ich möchte auch noch
was anderes machen
* Dynamische Musik *
Irgendwann ist es Zeit, loszulassen.
Irgendwann fängt etwas Neues an.
Vier Geschichten rund um Menschen,
die sich ins Abenteuer Nachfolge
wagen.
Rock'n'Roll und Hemden
sind seine Passion.
Eine ausgewählte Kundschaft kauft
bei ihm im ComeBack in Bern ein.
Markus gehört zu jenen vier,
die wir auf ihrem Weg begleiten.
Am allerbesten lassen sich
diese Hemden hier verkaufen.
Es ist dieser Bereich.
Lustigerweise gerade geschnittene
Hemden, nicht taillierte.
Diese Hemden kaufen
auch ältere Personen.
Das Alter geht von 40 bis 70 Jahren.
Die Jüngeren
kaufen die taillierten Hemden.
Ich trage am liebsten ...
Was trage ich?
Diese Rich Friday.
Diese Hemden haben spezielle Sujets.
Welche ich auch sehr mag,
sind diese italienischen, die Xacus.
Wie geht's? - Gut, danke.
Ich war gerade in Prag.
Ah, ja dann geht's gut.
Markus ist inzwischen 72, und
das ComeBack gibt es seit 24 Jahren.
Der Wunschkandidat ist jemand,
der das eins zu eins übernimmt
und mit diesen Hemden
weiterfahren will.
Das kann auch eine Frau sein.
Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen,
dass das eine Frau auch kann.
Man erklärt alles.
Branchenkundig muss man nicht sein.
Es reicht, Freude daran zu haben.
300'000 Fr. will Markus -
mit Beratung und Kontakten.
Die Person ist da,
sie kommt eines Tages herein.
So einfach ist das.
* Telefon *
Voilà, vielen Dank.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Fröhliches Pfeifen *
* Sanfte Musik, Hunde bellen *
* Sanfte Musik, Vogelzwitschern *
Ich sei der Velopfarrer, sagen sie.
Tschau!
Der Velopfarrer von Ostermundigen -
das ist Peter Christen.
Salü, Vreni.
Tschau!
Bei ihm ist der Abschied konkret.
Mit 65 geht er in Pension.
Ein letztes Mal
besucht er seine Schäfchen.
Ich habe den Bergpreis gewonnen,
Frau Jost.
Kommen Sie herein.
Sie haben eine so schöne Wohnung.
Wunderbar!
Schön, sind Sie hier.
Ich habe es versprochen. Ich wäre
auch als Pensionierter gekommen.
Die Pension rückt näher.
Ich weiss fast nicht mehr, wann.
Heute Morgen
fühlte es sich seltsam an.
Der Abschied ist mir irgendwie
im falschen Hals stecken geblieben.
Wirklich!
Ich interpretiere das langsam
als eine Form von Abschiedsschmerz,
den ich so empfinde.
Auf jeden Fall spüren Sie das.
Oh, Ihre Frau wird sich freuen,
nicht wahr?
Sie hat Angst!
Natürlich.
Ich bin zu Hause und sie kommt
von der Arbeit nach Hause.
Dann hat man das Gefühl, man sollte
noch Velo fahren, laufen gehen,
man sollte dieses und jenes ...
Und ich bin kaputt.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es sich anfühlt - definitiv.
Eine tolle Frau
tritt meine Nachfolge an.
Das ist nicht dasselbe.
- Natürlich nicht.
Sie kann auch gut sein, sicher.
Ja, es ist eine ganz liebe.
Es ist nicht dasselbe wie bei Ihnen,
der 27 Jahre lang da ist
und den man im Dorf kennt.
* Glockenläuten *
* Kirchlicher Gesang setzt ein. *
Seine Nachfolgerin
heisst Aline Berger.
Sie ist 27 und noch in Ausbildung
im Vikariat in Zollikofen.
Wir gehen
das Kirchengesangbuch durch.
Ich kenne viele Lieder davon nicht.
Ich wähle immer
ein bisschen dieselben aus.
Oder ich suche eines
mit einem schönen Text
und dann kennt es kein Schwein.
"Oh Heiland, reiss die Himmel auf"
nehme ich auch.
Sie ist weit weg
von einem dogmatischen Glauben.
Das streiche ich rot an,
das kommt auf die rote Liste.
Lieder, in denen es um Teufel,
Sünde und Gericht geht ...
Das sind so Schlagwörter.
Die entsprechen nicht
meiner Theologie.
Höchstens sprachliche Metaphern.
Ich sage immer: "Einen Gott,
den es gibt, gibt es nicht."
Also weder eine Wolke noch ...
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Nichts, das man anfassen kann.
Aber ...
Es ist eher etwas, das sich
zwischen den Menschen ereignet.
Eine heilige Kraft.
Oder in der Natur.
In der Schönheit der Natur
sehe ich überall Gott.
Ja.
# Morning has broken
like the first morning.
* Sanfter Popsong "Morning
Has Broken" von Cat Stevens *
# Blackbird has spoken
like the first bird.
Für mich ist es halt
eine Mischung zwischen ...
Es war einfach sehr schön.
Diese Begegnungen.
Sie erlebt zu haben,
das ist einfach extrem schön.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge "Morning
Has Broken", fröhliches Pfeifen *
Hu! Juhu!
* Rockige Klänge *
Markus war schon immer innovativ.
Das ComeBack ist bereits
sein zweiter Laden.
In den wilden Sixties
in Paris und London
begann die Geschichte
des ersten Geschäfts.
Vom ersten Tag,
vom ersten Kassenbuch ...
... bis ...
In diesem zweiten Album
ist beinahe alles drin,
was in 50 Jahren geschehen ist.
Das war am 14. Juli 1968.
Da habe ich in Paris
mein blaues Wunder erlebt!
Ich war 21 Jahre alt
und hatte nicht viel Ahnung,
wie ein Geschäftsleben aussieht.
Trice - ein Freund hat empfohlen,
das Geschäft so zu nennen.
Ich hatte eine Freundin,
die Beatrice hiess.
Er meinte, Trice sei die
englische Abkürzung für Beatrice.
So ist das entstanden.
In Bern gab es
keine solchen Kleider.
Kein Warenhaus
führte damals eine Boutique.
Die Mädchen, die wussten, dass ich
in England einkaufe, warteten.
Am Samstagmorgen
haben sie die Sachen,
die man nachts ausgepackt hat,
gleich aus dem Karton weggekauft.
Das bin ich.
Ich trug knallgelbe Latzhosen.
Ha!
Die Sachen, die man verkaufen
wollte, musste man auch anziehen.
Mir gefiel das, deshalb bin ich
ja auch darauf gestossen.
Das war unser Skandalplakat.
Es löste in der ganzen Schweiz
einen Skandal aus.
Es sei sexistisch.
Wir wurden
als Kinderschänder beschimpft
und wir erhielten Telefonanrufe.
Das war ganz krass.
Die beste Werbung!
"Der Apfel der Versuchung" - dass
sich die beiden bei uns anziehen.
Das war die Idee des Plakats.
Singen mit Simone.
Hat man es gestern gehört?
Dem Apfel der Versuchung ist sogar
eine künftige Pfarrerin wie Aline
im realen Leben nicht gewappnet.
Aline ist frisch verliebt -
in ihren Freund Jan Gnägi.
Ein Sommermärchen.
Jan und ich arbeiten
schon eine Weile Tür an Tür im Büro.
Und, ja ...
Diese Woche haben wir
eine Mail an die anderen geschickt:
Unser Verhältnis
habe sich nun privatisiert.
Wir haben beide eine Woche Ferien
in Venedig gemacht,
ohne dass wir es
vom anderen wussten.
Im Büro haben wir gemerkt, dass wir
gleichzeitig da sein würden.
Und dann, ja ...
Es hat sich so ergeben.
Noch nicht da.
Es hat noch Monate gedauert.
Ja, eigentlich ...
Jetzt ...
Jetzt bin ich offiziell liiert -
in der Kirchgemeinde
und auf Facebook
und überall und so.
Wie es sich
für eine angehende Pfarrerin gehört.
Die Verhältnisse sind geklärt.
- Ja, genau.
Zu seinen besten Zeiten führte
Markus drei Filialen gleichzeitig.
aber die Konkurrenz schlief nicht.
Am 30. November 1994
war der letzte Tag vom Shop Trice.
Es war auch der letzte Tag
von meinem Haus.
Und die damalige Freundin ist
gleichzeitig auch noch ausgezogen.
Und, ähm ...
Da hatte ich einen Moment ...
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich könne das locker nehmen.
Ich sah es kommen und wusste es,
aber es war trotzdem happig.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie es weitergehen würde.
Mit den letzten paar Tausend Franken
bin ich nach Amerika verreist.
Nach einer Woche
habe ich mich gefangen und gewusst,
was ich wollte:
nämlich zurück und neu anfangen.
Und zwar mit der allerersten Idee:
nur Hemden.
Ich glaube schon,
dass die Leute z.T. schauen.
V.a. kennen mich mehr Leute
als umgekehrt.
Aber hier ...
In diesem Teil von Zollikofen
kann ich ganz inkognito
jede Woche mit einem neuen Mann
herumlaufen.
Ich hoffe es einfach nicht.
- Nein, nein.
In letzter Zeit mehr mit Jan.
Ich habe auch schon abends
Konfirmanden gesehen.
Entweder war ich im Ausgang
oder sie.
Dann heisst es:
Ah, grüezi Frau Berger!
Ja, und dann ...
Dann merke ich,
dass ich ja Frau Berger bin.
Du bist schon ...
Dich beobachtet man schon.
Ja.
Zusammen wohnen ist für Aline und Jan
momentan kein Thema.
In Ostermundigen, wo sie
als künftige Pfarrerin gewählt wurde,
wohnt sie auch nicht im Pfarrhaus,
sondern in einer eigenen Wohnung.
* Blöken *
- Nein, keine Angst haben.
Komm! Komm rasch!
Das Pfarramt in Ostermundigen ist
auf vier Pfarrpersonen aufgeteilt.
Jede hat ihre Spezialaufgaben.
Für Peter Christen
ist es u.a. die KUW,
die kirchliche Unterweisung
für die Mittelstufe.
* Blöken *
Ja, jetzt findest du sie nicht.
Das ist auch Leben.
Das ist ganz, ganz echtes
und tiefes Leben.
Und wenn die Kinder das sehen ...
Ich sage ihnen,
sie sollen sie streicheln,
damit sie den Geruch riechen.
Komm, du musst da rauf!
Wir kommen wieder, in Ordnung?
* Sanfte Klaviermusik, Blöken *
(Er liest) Ben, der Nachbar war.
Ich bin so dankbar,
dass es das letzte Mal ist.
Die Energie, die man aufwendet,
ist enorm.
Das fordert mich extrem.
Und gleichzeitig ...
... ist auch etwas Trauer da.
Jöh, schaut mal!
Hallo!
Peter Christen
hat zuerst Dachdecker gelernt
und ist erst nachher
Pfarrer geworden.
Dachdecker war nicht seine Welt.
Er merkte, dass es ihn reizte,
als Pfarrer mit Menschen zu arbeiten.
Tschau! Du bist Joe, oder?
Alina.
Grüezi, Felix.
Sinn und Zweck ist eigentlich ...
In der fünften Klasse lernen sie
das Bibelbuch vertiefter kennen.
Sie sollen sich mit der Welt,
der Umwelt von dieser Bibel
bekannt machen.
Sie sollen lernen, wie die Menschen
damals gelebt haben,
was sie gegessen
was sie gearbeitet haben.
Was wichtig war.
Dann steigen wir ein
in eine uralte, schöne Geschichte.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Du gefällst mir, Mutter.
Nun dürft ihr reinkommen
und sie streicheln.
Diese gehören zu ihr.
Sie trug sie nur fünf Monate
im Bauch,
dann wurden sie schon geboren.
(Kind) Dann sieht man den Kopf?
- Ja.
* Dynamische Schlagzeugmusik *
Ein grosser Tag für Markus.
Die Rolling Stones
kommen in die Schweiz.
Das ist das erste Mal
seit 23 Jahren,
dass ich mit einem T-Shirt
im Geschäft stehe.
Heute ist das so.
Heute muss man das machen.
Heute passt das! Wenn man schon
an das Stones Konzert darf.
Die Geschichte der Rolling Stones
ist eng mit Markus Leben verbunden.
Bevor er angefangen hat,
mit Kleidern zu handeln,
hat er in Paris
Poster von Rockstars erstanden
und gewinnbringend
weiterverkauft.
Dieses Bild machte Furore.
Das erste farbige Stones-Poster,
das es überhaupt gab.
So unglaublich das klingt!
Es gab zu jener Zeit -
das war 1969/1970 -
nur schwarz-weisse Poster.
In London habe ich
mit einem Mietauto
sofort zweimal
3'000 Stück verkauft.
Man staunte,
dass die Poster farbig waren.
Mit dem Geld sollten eigentlich
die Druckereien bezahlt werden.
Die Hälfte habe ich ausgegeben,
um Mini-Kleider zu kaufen,
weil es die in Bern noch nicht gab.
Innert zwei Tagen
waren sie verkauft.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es mein Geschäft
ohne Stones gäbe.
Das gab schon den Impuls
und die Idee für die Hemden.
Ob ich sonst darauf gekommen wäre,
wer weiss das!
* Glockenläuten *
Noch ist Peter Christen
Pfarrer von Ostermundigen.
Der Pfarrer, der predigt und tauft.
Guten Morgen! Schön, sind Sie hier.
Zu seiner letzten Taufe ist auch
Aline, seine Nachfolgerin, gekommen.
Herzlich willkommen, liebe Gemeinde,
zu diesem Gottesdienst.
Schön, dass Sie da sind.
Schön auch, dass Sie
als Familie Blaser da sind.
Sie sind mit Leonie da.
Und Sie, Frau Schatzmann,
Sie sind mit Iliriana da.
Wir wollen die beiden Kinder
heute taufen
und so in die Gemeinschaft
der christlichen Kirche aufnehmen.
Sie sagten, Sie würden das noch
wollen, bevor ich pensioniert werde.
Ich solle diese Taufe
noch machen dürfen.
Das dünkt mich wunderschön!
Leonie nennen Sie sie.
Das ist die weibliche Form von Leo.
Der Löwe - die Starke, die Kräftige.
Iliriana.
Ich musste viel üben,
damit ich den Namen wirklich
schön sauber sagen kann.
So nennen Sie Ihre Tochter.
Der Hauptgrund für Markus,
einen Nachfolger zu suchen,
ist seine Freundin Ingrid,
die auch aufhört zu arbeiten.
Zusammen sind sie unterwegs
ans Stones-Konzert.
Wir möchten gerne
noch ein wenig reisen.
Das geht natürlich nicht,
wenn das Geschäft noch da ist.
Sie wird bald pensioniert.
In zwei Jahren. Oder anderthalb?
- Anderthalb.
Es wäre gut, wenn das
bis dahin geschafft wäre.
Aber es muss nicht sein.
Muss nicht sein!
Ich stehe nicht unter Druck.
Ich hoffe, dass es spätestens
bis dahin erledigt ist.
Wenn das nun ...
Geschieht es erst in zwei oder in
anderthalb Jahren, ist mir das egal.
Geschieht es nächste Woche,
ist es mir auch egal.
Ich nehme zumindest an,
dass es mir egal ist.
Ja ...
Ich möchte nicht, dass Markus
unter Druck ist. Überhaupt nicht.
Interessiert sich jemand
für das Geschäft, ist es gut
und wenn es klappt, ist es auch gut.
Der Zeitrahmen
spielt eigentlich keine Rolle.
* Ingrid lacht. *
Gemütlich, sehr gemütlich
würden wir es angehen.
Zuerst würden wir
eine Ferienplanung machen. - Ja.
Das ist das Erste.
Die erste Reise
würde wohl nach Amerika gehen.
Ja, wir lieben Amerika.
Als Reiseland. Der Rest
interessiert uns eigentlich nicht.
Man muss gesund bleiben,
um diese Sachen zu erledigen
und die Träume zu erfüllen.
Spielt die Gesundheit nicht mit,
ist eh nichts.
Man darf nicht
mit etwas Negativem rechnen.
* Leidenschaftlicher Rocksong "I Got
The Blues" von The Rolling Stones *
Leonie Blaser.
Ich taufe dich im Namen des Vaters,
der dich geschaffen hat.
Ich taufe dich im Namen
von Jesus Christus, seinem Sohn.
Ich taufe dich
im Namen des Heiligen Geistes,
der Kraft Gottes,
die dich belebt.
Dir gebe ich keine KUW mit.
Nein. Nein.
Es bewegt mich jedes Mal.
Es tut mir so ...
Es erzeugt in mir ein Gefühl
von Freude und Befriedigung.
Ich geniesse den Moment
jedes Mal selber.
Es ist nicht irgendwie nur so ...
Bereits 1967 war Markus am legendären
Stones-Konzert im Hallenstadion.
Damals flogen Stühle und Bänke.
# I told you once
and I told you twice.
Dass wir zusammen
eine gute Zeit verbringen
und ein gutes Konzert erleben.
Dass wir das überhaupt
noch einmal erleben dürfen,
ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Wir freuen uns darauf.
Die Stones hat er inzwischen
mind. 20-mal gesehen.
# Well this could be the last time.
In Ostermundigen zeigt Peter Christen
seiner Nachfolgerin seine Kirche.
Der Ort des Geschehens.
Da ist zuerst einmal
etwas Katholisches.
Katholisch? Warum?
Ein Kerzentisch gehört nicht
wirklich in die reformierte Kirche.
Das hat sich eingebürgert.
- Ja.
Das ist das jüngste Teil,
welches wir hier haben.
Es soll etwas ...
Es ist etwas
an diesen Plastiken angelehnt.
Auf dem Loosli-Zeug ...
Die Formen aufnehmen,
wie z.B. diese Kreise.
Ja. Gefällt mir besser
als jenes dort.
Gefällt dir das nicht? - Überhaupt
nicht! - Mir gefällt es so gut.
Ich komme trotzdem
nach Ostermundigen.
Kommst du trotzdem
nach Ostermundigen?
Jener gefällt mir nicht schlecht.
Weisst du, mir gefällt er auch.
Und der Tisch? Kannst du daran?
Soll man für dich
einen neuen machen?
Nein, den finde ich schön.
Du, übrigens.
Predigst du so?
Nein.
- Hihi, hi.
Ich ziehe wohl den Talar an.
- Hast du einen? - Nein.
Willst du einen?
- Ja, vielleicht.
Im Moment ziehe ich
jenen von Simone an.
Es ist ein Frauentalar,
ohne Beffchen.
Ohne Beffchen. Ein liturgisches
Gewand sollte es sein.
Ja, vermutlich schon einen Talar,
sonst brauche ich zu viele Kleider.
Es ist zwar eine neue Kirche,
gut 70 Jahre alt.
Also, ja, neu ...
Relativ - im Vergleich zu vielen
alten Kirchen, Moosseedorf z.B.
Das sind ururalte Kirchen.
Diese ist relativ neu.
- Ja.
Für mich hat sie eine Seele.
Gleich von Anfang an
war es mir wohl hier.
Es war mir immer wohl.
Viele tolle Geschichten
sind damit verbunden.
Nur schon deswegen
zeige ich dir das gerne.
Das ist mit Leben verbunden.
Ich bin stolz, dass das sein durfte.
Es ist nicht die schönste Kirche
auf der Welt, aber ...
Aber, ähm, ...
- Aber, aber ...
Aber man kann sie brauchen.
Man erstarrt nicht gleich
vor Ehrfurcht.
Und man darf es wagen,
etwas umzustellen.
Ich glaube, man kann ...
Man kann z.B. zeigen,
was die Kinder machen.
* Räuspern *
Im Pfarramt ist nicht mehr,
was drin war.
Meine Güte! Es ist so anders.
Als wäre ich drei-,
viermal umgezogen.
Es fühlt sich so an.
Und ich konnte so viel erreichen.
Ich muss hier nichts mehr tun.
Es ist alles nur noch schön.
Du darfst mich mal für eine Lesung
fragen. Das mache ich gerne. - Ja?
Sicher.
- Ah, ja. Das wäre noch so ...
Weisst du ...
- Es bleibt etwas von dir hier.
Aber, sei so gut, nur dann,
wenn es für dich stimmt.
Nicht weil du gehört hast,
ich würde es gerne machen.
Ich will einfach nicht,
dass du das Gefühl hast,
ich würde ständig kontrollieren.
Blödsinn!
Du bist jetzt Pfarrerin.
Ich sagte,
ich wolle lange langweilen.
Ich lasse dich hier raus.
Dann kannst du gleich gehen.
* Fetzige Musik "It's Only
Rock'n'Roll" von The Rolling Stones *
# ... but I like it, yes, I do.
# Oh, well, I like it.
# I like it.
Das war nicht wirklich schlecht.
Nein, es ist nach wie vor das Beste.
Wir sind begeistert.
Wir haben es so erwartet.
Es war einmal mehr super.
Es könnte sein,
dass es das letzte Mal war.
Sie haben schon ...
Charlie Watts ist älter geworden.
Aber eben, er ist 76 Jahre alt.
Es gibt nichts zu reklamieren.
Es war gut. Super!
Die Vergänglichkeit
und der Gedanke daran,
dass alles einmal ein Ende hat
und man loslassen muss,
ist eine Regel des Lebens.
Guten Morgen!
Aline als angehende Pfarrerin wird
auch Menschen in den Tod begleiten.
Schön,
dass es nun endlich einmal klappt.
Um sich selbst ein Bild machen
zu können, was nach dem Leben ist,
geht sie zu einem Bestatter.
Wann trittst du
Christens Nachfolge an?
Erst im November.
- November.
Mein Vikariat
dauert bis Ende September.
Danach habe ich noch einen Monat,
um irgendetwas zu tun.
Ich habe erst etwa zwei tote
Menschen in meinem Leben gesehen.
Künftig werde ich wohl
viele Menschen beerdigen müssen.
Es ist gut, wenn ich mal ...
Ich bin jetzt 27 Jahre alt.
Meine Grossväter sind tot -
andere aber nicht.
Ich habe noch keinen
nahestehenden Menschen verloren.
Nahe ... also wegen dem ich eine
lange Trauerphase gehabt hätte.
Darum möchte ich auf dieses Thema
einen besonderen Fokus legen.
Ah, richtig, ein Leichenwagen.
* Rasche Orgelmusik *
Auch in Hergiswil
wird ein Nachfolger gesucht.
Und zwar für den Hausarzt
Martin Sigg.
Seit 35 Jahren ist er hier tätig.
Nächstes Jahr wird er 70
und sein Ziel ist klar:
dann will er pensioniert werden.
Geht es gut?
- Ja, ja.
Dr. Sigg, wie sie ihn in Hergiswil
nennen, ist einer von ihnen.
Hier aufgewachsen und
mit seinen Patienten alt geworden.
Salü, Peter.
- Comu est ás?
Come state?
- Bene. E lei? - Si.
Lei è venuto
per chiedere il resultato?
Si, per parlarne con te.
Ah, si. Okay.
Facciamo cosi. Va bene?
Arriverderci. - Ciao.
Tschau, Peter.
- Tschau, Martin.
Gibst du mir die Agenda?
Dann kann ich es nachsehen.
Als Hausarzt ist es wichtig,
dass man auf die Leute eingeht
und sie ernst nimmt.
Man muss versuchen, sie ganzheitlich
zu sehen, im Kontext,
mit der Familie, dem Beruf.
Vermutlich ist das als Hausarzt
unser Vorteil.
Wir wissen, wo sie arbeiten.
Wir kennen die Familienverhältnisse.
Wir wissen, wie sie aufgewachsen
sind und wir wissen auch,
wo etwa die kritischen Punkte
in der Familiengeschichte liegen.
Banker, Arbeiter, Bauern -
sie kommen alle zu Martin Sigg.
Morgen!
- (leise) Guten Tag, Herr Dr. Sigg.
Also, Sie kommen heute wegen der
Motorfahrzeug-Kontrolluntersuchung.
Würden Sie sich bitte
obenrum freimachen,
damit ich Sie untersuchen kann?
Sie können es sich ja leisten,
Sie sind schlank geblieben.
Das kann man sagen. - Das ist gut.
Immer noch viel auf dem Velo? - Ja.
Nach rechts, nach oben ...
Hinunter, weit weg schauen,
schielen.
Hören Sie alles, was Sie wollen?
- Das, was ich will - genau!
Das ist richtig interpretiert.
Ich habe dich lange nicht mehr gese-
hen, darum habe ich nicht reagiert.
Darum habe ich nichts gesagt.
* Sie reden gleichzeitig. *
Es ist wahr, ich war schon lange
nicht mehr hier, zum Glück.
Die ganze Familiensippe ...
Ich glaube, es sind alle hier.
- Das stimmt.
Bück dich nach vorne hinunter
und lass die Arme hängen!
Ja - und jetzt wieder raufkommen.
Eher mehr im Lenden- oder
im Brustwirbelsäulenbereich?
Eher Brustwirbel.
Vor dem Hirnschlag waren es 68 kg.
- Ja, so ungefähr.
Machst du mit deinen Tattoos
eine Pause?
Oder hast du schon neue Projekte?
- Im Moment mache ich Pause.
Auch die Haut braucht das.
- Das denke ich schon.
Besser als letztes Mal.
- Ja.
* Sie reden gleichzeitig. *
132/88 - jetzt ist er wieder normal.
Dann bin ich ja froh.
Du hattest schon einiges.
Zu vieles, muss man sagen, oder?
Ich habe oft gedacht,
dass ich ohne Martin nicht gewusst
hätte, was ich machen sollte.
Vielleicht wäre ich
gar nicht mehr am Leben.
Ja, also wirklich: Hut ab!
Den Gedanken aufzuhören, trägt er
seit zwei, drei Jahren mit sich.
Aber jetzt geht er
das Abenteuer Nachfolge konkret an.
Mein Beruf ist natürlich ...
Seit 35 Jahren bin ich von
meinen Arztgehilfinnen verwaltet.
Das klingt nicht schön,
aber sie schreiben die Patienten ein
und geben mir den Takt vor,
wo, wie viel und wann
ich arbeiten muss.
Ich sehne mich nach der Zeit ...
Ist es draussen schön,
möchte ich sagen können:
"Heute gehe ich Ski fahren
oder ich gehe auf den See."
"Ich gehe rudern, Töff fahren."
"Ich gehe auf die Jagd
oder was auch immer."
Ich muss mir dann nicht mehr sagen,
es liege nicht drin.
Wer arbeitet, hat immer das Gefühl,
während der Woche sei es schön,
am Wochenende regne es.
Das ist so etwas!
Ich möchte wieder Freiheit haben.
Ich möchte die Freiheit haben,
den Tag selbst zu gestalten.
* Dynamische Orgelmusik *
Um mehr über den Umgang
mit dem Tod zu erfahren,
greift Aline heute dem Bestatter
unter die Arme.
... in die Aufbahrungsräume.
Hast du angeklopft?
Jetzt nehmen wir
die ganzen Blumen weg,
damit wir dann mit dem Wagen
rausfahren können.
Sie sehen einfach schon ...
... nicht lebendig aus.
Aber friedlich.
- Friedlich, ja.
Die Leichenblässe.
Das ist wirklich etwas anderes.
Wir löschen noch das Licht.
Es ist halt ein Kreislauf.
Ja ...
Dafür sind wir da ...
Für die Lebensübergänge ...
Rites de passage, damit die Leute
gut Abschied nehmen können.
Heute ist der Tod
für die meisten ...
... etwas überhaupt
nicht Alltägliches.
Machen Sie das hier draussen!
In der Regel sind wir sehr, sehr
still bei den verstorbenen Menschen.
Ich habe gestaunt darüber,
dass sie es wirklich so ernst nehmen
und nicht ein bisschen reden und so.
Ich habe auch schon ...
Ich dachte eher,
dass man es lockerer nimmt,
um selbst Distanz zu gewinnen.
Es hat mich beeindruckt,
dass es ihm sehr wichtig ist,
dass es wirklich ruhig ist.
Für mich persönlich
ist es auch wichtig.
Ja ...
Es gibt andere Kulturkreise ...
Da ist man um einen Sarg herum ...
Jemand ist aufgebahrt
oder der Körper
ist auf einem Stuhl aufgebahrt.
Die Leute spielen Gitarre
und und und ...
Aber das haben wir hier nicht.
Dann kann man sagen,
dass man das hier akzeptiert.
Es ist für mich nicht befremdend,
es in einem anderen Land
so zu sehen.
Varanasi z.B.
Genau, oder bei den Filipinos
im Norden. Da war es so.
Aber hier herrscht einfach
eine gewisse Demut
gegenüber der verstorbenen Person.
* Schleppende, brummende Musik *
Es ist noch warm, nicht?
In der nächsten Folge treffen wir
die junge Familie Wieland,
die sich einen Traum erfüllen kann.
Als Nachfolger will sie
auf diesem Hof im Emmental
einen modernen Bauernbetrieb
aufziehen.
Markus ist vielleicht zum letzten Mal
auf Einkaufstour in Paris.
Ça ne va pas.
- Ça non?
Ihre Medikamente.
Als Hausarzt besucht Martin Sigg
seine Patienten auch zu Hause.
...72. Das ist gut.
Ach, tschau, Peter.
Und Aline Berger
hat ihren ersten Arbeitstag.
Danke.
Das und noch mehr Geschichten in der
nächsten Folge "Abenteuer Nachfolge".